peter king joining us hi Peter Dan
there's nothing that you can't ask me
that I won't know everything about if I
told you a week ago the Browns are gonna
take Baker Mayfield you would have said
what I would have said I'm surprised but
not shocked because a week ago I came
out with my mock draft
I gave him Sam Donald and on Sunday
night a week ago I was told
categorically absolutely they're not
taking Josh Alan so I figured that it
was going to be Sam darn 'old probably
but I just didn't know and I think what
happened and I wrote a lot about this
this morning in my column is that John
Dorsey did for about five weeks I mean I
think he's known for five weeks exactly
what he was going to do and I think
until about the last 48 hours he did a
great job of making sure nobody else
knew I also look at the strategy here
and and look I I don't know if Baker
Mayfield is going to be good or if
Denzel Ward's gonna be good I just was
trying to figure out the philosophy of
what the Browns were doing it like what
was the game plan here that you had
Chubb or you had Berkeley could you have
gotten Berkeley taking Berkeley at 1:00
and then taking your quarterback either
darn old or Mayfield at 4:00 what did
you think of that possible game Mayfield
was far ahead of everybody D and they
were taking a quarterback at number one
they weren't going to take a running
back they're just okay they they've been
fooling around at quarterback for too
long I mean you know the last time the
Cleveland Browns took a quarterback in
the top 20 was 1999 so you know they
just been farting around with the
quarterback too long they had a
conviction you know I think the top for
scouting people in their organization
independently said that we think that
Mayfield is the best guy so after that
was decided I don't think there was ever
a question who they were going to take
now let's talk about Denzel Ward
in my opinion and and Greg Williams the
defensive coordinator the Browns told me
three things number one that they have a
tape a video of 28 plays from 2017 where
Miles Garrett is within a step or two of
the quarterback when he releases the
ball but just doesn't have enough time
to get to him he said miles Garrett had
a really good year it just didn't show
up in the numbers because we couldn't
cover that's number one number two
Emanuel Agua on the other side of the
field according to Williams he thinks he
could be eventually a Bradley Chubb type
of force in their defense and I think
the third thing about all of this is
they play a lot of press man coverage
and far and away Denzel Ward was the
number one guy doing that in the league
they plan to put Denzel Ward on Antonio
Brown and AJ Green and say okay let the
best man win
talking to Peter King the mmq b.com
joining us Dan Patrick show the Giants
draft strategy at two you normally don't
take a running back at two and Sam
Darnell then goes to three so your
thoughts on just taking a running back
at number two overall by the Giants I
mean I'm not a fan of it but I
understand why they did it
Dave gentlemen last year picked
Christian McCaffrey eight he strongly
strongly believes in traditional
football and a strong running game and I
think he also feels like with the
weapons that they have a healthy Odell
Beckham sterling Shepherd one of the
best young tight ends in football and
Evan Engram that that's going to mask
whatever the issues have been with Eli
Manning and that Eli Manning who now
will be a complementary player and not a
guy who's got to beat the New England
Patriots in the Super Bowl necessarily I
think he believes that that they're
going to have a better chance to be a
much better all-around offense and think
of it this team hasn't had a great
running backs in
Tiki Barber and so I just think that for
the Dave Gettleman way of building a
team this pic made the most sense give
me your head scratcher
whatever round it was I think the head
scratcher probably more than anything
else was Josh Jackson going to the
second round in Green Bay I know that
sounds weird for being a head scratcher
but he's such a good playmaker he's I
think he's Richard Sherman 2.0 I don't
know if he'll be as good in the NFL but
he's a slower guy he's a four or five
corner but who's got a great nose for
the football and I think he's going to
be a very good NFL corner the other
thing was I thought Arizona did a great
not a good but a great job in moving
from 15 to 10 for a quarterback and not
giving up either next year's one or a
second-round pick they traded a three
and a five and I think that was a really
good move by on their part and you know
Oakland probably had no other
significant offer and I believe after
Oakland lost Mike McGlinchey to the San
Francisco 49ers that it made any trade
down attractive because they knew they
wanted a tackle and they knew taking
Colton Miller at number 10 would be
stupid so they get some benefit moving
down to 15 but it's not to me what the
market said it should be yeah I love
what the packers did with those
defensive backs those are guys who play
right away the other aspect of what I
found fascinating is that once we had
the Jason Witten news that maybe he was
gonna go to Monday Night Football now
where the Cowboys gonna pull the trigger
on a tight end in the second round and
when the Eagles leapfrogged them to take
the kid out of South Dakota State I
thought man that that one looked like it
stunned the Dallas Cowboys was down was
taking Dallas Goddard I don't know if
they were not in I think they obviously
were in need of a tight end but I just
don't know I think the irony is rich
though that that a quarter that a tight
end named Dallas gets picked in Dallas
and not by
to Cowboys and and that's a position of
great need for them no matter what
Witten does I mean I assume like
everybody else that Jason Witten is
gonna do TV but it sure looked like the
Eagles pulled one off on the Cowboys why
wouldn't wouldn't do Monday Night
Football I have no idea I think because
the only reason is because he still
loves football and then you remember
last year I did a story on him for for
football night in America basically
about what his routine was to get ready
our to heal on Monday and and I was with
him for seven hours on Monday this guy
in year 15 had has had the zeal of a
rookie and he still really loved
football when we talked he talked about
playing multiple years so I'm sure that
it isn't easy regardless of the fact
that this is probably going to be your
next career I'm sure it's not easy to
stop doing something that has a finite
life anyway and and and and you don't
want to leave it quite yet but as Tony
Romo's did last year sometimes you don't
have a choice
of when these jobs open up oh I would
run to that Monday Night Football yeah
I'd run because he's already got a Hall
of Fame resume I'd also say this day and
you know to me I think a lot of times
and you would know this far better than
I but I've always had the impression
that sometimes if you get into TV
sometimes you're better working for you
know I'm gonna make this up you know
Comcast Dallas you know first or
something you know - yeah - work for two
or three years instead of opening on
this gigantic stage because everybody
can't be Tony Romo I mean even
Collinsworth you know had a few years
with the training wheels on you know so
I I and look I'm not
I think Jason Witten is going to do a
very good job but I'm saying sometimes I
think it's good to get a little batting
practice in double-a before you're
called up to
Yankees one final point here Schad Khan
trying to buy Wembley and then I'm gonna
paraphrase the quote that it's almost
like saying hey by getting Wembley I'm
further ensuring the Jackson but you
know Jackson Ville keeps the Jaguar yeah
I didn't quite get that one I thought
that was I thought that was a very very
interesting logic you know by by Shaad
Cobb who and I have to tell you this
shot Khan has been a fantastic owner in
Jacksonville but at some point he is
going to have the opportunity without
any doubt in my mind he's going to have
the opportunity to move his franchise
and so I mean is he going to take that
opportunity is he not I don't know he
insists that he is not I'll take him at
his word but it doesn't really it's not
very logical to me to say hey I'm buying
the most iconic stadium in Europe and
and I want to play football games over
if we play football games over here
every year every year ergo this
strengthens the Jacksonville Jaguars I I
don't I don't really get it okay we'll
see here's part of the quote the
stronger the Jaguars are in London the
more stable and promising the Jaguars
future will be in Jacksonville boy I
don't know if I would pony up for season
tickets there for Jacksonville long-term
I know I would because the Jaguars are
good you know and they're gonna be fun
to watch and you know look nobody knows
what the future holds
you no one knows if you're gonna get hit
by a car walking off the curb tomorrow
so I mean enjoy that team because that
team is gonna be fun to watch in a very
Coughlin Marone esque kind of way
Pete great stuff in the column today
thanks for joining us and we'll talk
soon all the best damn thank you and
that's Peter King and Peter fired up
their I think that's where you can
exhale nice got time to exhale a little
bit for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience
2:39 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]